All right, so
based on what we just talked through,
weight 0's going to keep going
up after each of these updates.
And in fact,
if you just plunk it through,
it's not particularly complicated that
after these first six updates at this
point weight 0 is about 10.4.
And now, we're going to finally do this
this last update of state 7 going back
to itself.
>> So
let's work through that update here.
>> Okay, well,
that should be pretty easy.
We just do what we did before,
we substitute in everything.
>> Okay.
>> So let's see, alpha's still 0.1.
>> Yeah.
>> R is still 0.
>> Gamma is still 0.9.
>> Yeah.
>> The value of 7 is, 7 times 10.4 plus,
I guess, still 1-
>> Yeah.
>> Which is 2.8, so 73.8.
>> I'll take that.
>> Minus the value of S, where we just
came from, which we just said was 73.8.
>> Yeah, so we're making a transition
from state 7 back to state 7.
And so the value of S and
the value of S prime are the same.
>> Right, and
then it's just the feature.
>> Which is?
>> Which is seven.
>> Seven.
>> And
that's equal to some kind of math thing.
That's not that hard.
It's minus 0.738 times 7.
>> Negative 5.166.
>> If you say so.
>> All right, so
that's kind of good news, right?
because this weight 0,
which had been getting pumped up and
up and up and
up is going to come back down a bit.
And, in fact, now-
>> False.
That's not good because w0 went up
a lot more than you're about to take
it back down.
>> Well, sure, yeah.
So weight 0, after all these updates
have happened, the weight is 5.234.
It started off at 1, recall,
and now it has actually blown
up quite substantially.
So this last update does help,
but it doesn't help enough.
Is that what you're getting at?
>> Yeah, and in fact, that's going to
keep happening because it didn't
matter that we started at one input.
But there's nothing magical about one.
The point is, it's going to keep getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger,
and that's actually true for
w1, w2, w3, w4, w5, w6, and w7.
>> Right, so if we finish this sequence
of updates and we go and do it again,
this weight 0 is going to
get pumped up even more.
Weights 1 through 6 are also
going to get pumped up.
Weight 7 is going down, but not enough
to make up for the rest of everybody.
So yeah, so this is bad, right?
So we just keep doing these
updates over and over again, and
we'd want them to converge.
We want them to kind of get to
the right numbers, and instead,
we're just spiraling out of control.
>> So,
they're going to converge to infinity.
>> I think that's kind of
the definition of not converging.
Well, it's one kind of not converging,
right?
It's diverging.
>> Well, that's depressing.
>> Yeah, so even in this,
what would otherwise be
a very well behaved example, doing what
is clearly the right thing in terms
of doing these weight updates
actually is not the right thing.
So yeah, so bad things happen.
>> So I think I can convince
myself just by staring at it that
if we happen to set all
the weights to start off as 0,
they won't ever move, and
the right thing will happen.
>> Should we check that?
>> Sure, let's give it a quick check.